there's not a lot of humor to be found
in wokism or safetyism or whatever you
want to call Modern left-wing ideology
but since it's Friday it's worth
acknowledging something that everyone
knows deep down which is that there are
a few things about it that are if we're
being honest pretty funny and here's one
of them most jurisdictions in this
country used to consider it a serious
offense to lie and call somebody gay you
know if somebody was straight and you
started spreading rumors that they're
secretly gay then until very recently
New York courts would punish you for
that without a second thought they'd
call it defamation per se you're making
up lies about somebody
but in 2021 all that changed the New
York appeals court ruled that actually
you can call people gay all you want and
it's not necessarily defamatory why is
that well because according to New York
Court judges if you lie and call
somebody gay if anything you're probably
improving the reputation in the
community rather than harming it that's
because being gay has become a status
symbol at least in places like Manhattan
so suggesting that somebody a secret
somebody is secretly gay it's like
calling someone uh secretly a
millionaire it's it's a compliment
whether it's true or not
it's kind of amusing when you think
about it New York is now so woke that
gay slurs at least in some cases are now
acceptable in that respect strangely
enough New York is quite different from
say the United Kingdom another hotbed of
leftism over there they don't take
kindly to unfounded accusations of
homosexuality we know that because this
week a team of police officers in Leeds
raided the home of a 16 year old
autistic girl suffering from scoliosis
what was the girl's crime well she said
that one of the officers that was on
this team of people arresting her look
like her lesbian relative that's all
this girl did
she didn't even imply that it was bad to
be a lesbian in any way she just said
that this woman this cop looked like a
lesbian and for that cops dragged her
away here's what that looked like
[Music]
you better come in your own house
don't worry
don't care
okay I'm telling you I thought you was
coming she's gonna be arrested tonight
homophobic
this is what the British Empire has
become they used to rule the world now
they scramble half the police department
in response to a teenager who says hey
you look like my lesbian Nana
now they're arresting a girl police are
arresting a girl because that girl hurt
the feelings of one of those police
officers
it's quite a fall from grace especially
given that the police officer in
question if we're being honest
um could definitely pass as a lesbian
whether she's trying to look that way or
not it is a convincing display let's
just say
and at least in civilized Progressive
Utopias like New York they celebrate
that kind of thing
you know you go up to a cop and say you
look like a lesbian the couple say well
thank you so much
the UK obviously hasn't thought this all
the way through though because by
arresting autistic kids who say that
women look like lesbians
um especially when they actually do look
like lesbians they're sending the
message that looking like a lesbian is a
bad thing it's you know a horrendous
insult but that's the opposite of what
the UK intends to do here really they're
trying to elevate LGBT people to a
special sacred status and protect their
feelings with the force of law even if
it means dragging a teenage girl to jail
kicking and screaming
but the truth is the United States isn't
far from becoming the UK where children
are sent to prison for offending the
government
um what happened to that girl in the UK
is quickly becoming a Hallmark of
so-called Western democracies recently
in Canada for example a pastor was
arrested for the crime of protesting
drag queens who are trying to
indoctrinate children I want you to
watch this news report carefully because
it's one of the most incredible Clips
you'll ever see watch
they should feel safe there should never
be an issue with safety a pastor who
tried to stop a drug reading session for
kids at the Seton Library last week has
been charged by Calgary police parents
now questioning if these events are safe
enough to attend with their kids police
were called when protesters interrupted
the library's reading with royalty event
that was being presented by drag
personalities to kids when several
protesters entered the room shouting
homophobic words at the children and
their parents 36 year old Pastor Derek
Scott Reimer was arrested and charged
with hate motivated crime for causing a
disturbance and one count of Mischief in
addition City of Calgary peace officers
have charged Reimer with six counts of
harassment under the public Behavior by
law police say the disturbance scared
the children who were at the reading
sessions now parents wonder if these
events are still safe to bring their
families
yes there should never be an issue with
safety says the woman police are are
questioning if the events are safe
says the reporter meanwhile they show
footage of the mob throwing the pastor
to the ground
and the message is pretty clear by
safety they mean you don't get to
question their behavior or their
viewpoints
you don't get to object when they
sexualize children
oh because they want to sexualize
Children safely and you're making it
unsafe
and if you do you'll get attacked and
thrown in jail
that's what they mean when they say
safety safety no longer means safety in
the traditional sense for a long time
now it's meant something closer to
emotional comfort
like that's what they mean when they say
safety to be safe is to feel good it is
to have nice feelings
and anyone who causes you to have not
nice feelings and to feel not good is
compromising your safety
this has been true in Canada for a while
a couple years ago a man who was a doubt
on his luck went on a rant at the office
of his local Member of Parliament it was
a woman named Catherine McKenna and
here's what he said watch
can you help me she says she's spending
five billion 10 billion a year on
infrastructure the PBO office Eve Giroux
says he's only spending 5 billion a year
what's up with that
I don't go to work every day for this to
steal our money you're all scumbags
you're all pieces of trash
scumbags you're all kid pieces
of trash just like Dustin Trudeau raping
kids we charity sorry kids in Africa
this money isn't for you this money for
Justin Trudeau and his family they
needed a lot more than you they need a
bigger yacht they need a bigger watch
they need five watches that are 20 grand
the scumbag pieces
I hope you all burning hell you're all
gonna get what you deserve you
traitors
scumbag pieces
all right so he yells a few harsh words
including a few that were bleeped out
um make some valid points as well we
should admit
but he never met any violent threats
and for that Catherine McKenna called
for a hate crime investigation and
authorities opened one you see in Canada
no one's allowed to say mean things to
politicians you can call conservatives
white supremacists all you want but
don't you dare attack the people in
power you know a company is looking out
for you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it and
this is great news for new and current
Pure Talk customers pure talk just added
data for every plan and includes a
mobile hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you considered pure talk
before but haven't made the switch take
a look again for just twenty dollars a
month you'll get unlimited talk text and
now 50 percent more 5G data plus their
new mobile hotspot that's why I love
Pure Talk they're veteran owned and they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com Walsh Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans as
many of you know we've been giving our
dog rough greens for a while now and we
love it our dog seems happier healthier
has more energy
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough grains is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
little did I know before I got rough
grains dog food is dead food everybody
knows that nutrition isn't Brown it's
green let rough grains boost your dog's
food back to life rough grains is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Mega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are Raven about rough grains
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
Green is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so you can try uh well you can well you
don't want to your dog can try it or you
either one of you can try it together a
free jumpstart trial bag can be at your
door in just a few business okay so go
to freeruffgreens.com Matt or call 844
Ruff 700 that's free
r-u-f-fgreens.com Matt or call 844 rough
700 today
in a free country which Canada of course
isn't you know cussing out politicians
would be considered a virtuous Act
if not a national pastime
a way to keep our leaders humble and on
their toes is a good thing
but in Canada it's a potential hate
crime
now we'd like to think that these
attacks on freedom of speech couldn't
happen here but the truth is they're
already happening here they're just not
getting a lot of coverage recently in
Watertown Wisconsin police arrested a
young Christian man for simply reading
the Bible on the sidewalk in the
vicinity of a public drag event but that
was all he was doing
standing on the sidewalk reading the
Bible
and watch what happens to him
serve one another
you better devour one another
[Music]
beware lest you be consumed by one
another
hey what are you doing
what is the problem
you think of any warning oh this is the
same one that we had in here yeah that
was in there it was not out here
they say we can have we can they say we
can speak out here in the sidewalk
freely
nobody told us that
how come there's no amplification what's
this uh you guys are acting like thugs
man you're like straight up thugs hey
you're you're taking away my pain he has
every right to be out here engaging in
speech
he has every right to be out here
engaging in speech
yeah is that right to be out here
engaging in speech the guy holding the
camera says then he's right but we don't
live in a country that cares about that
sort of thing anymore uh Marcus Traders
the man who was arrested for reading the
Bible there later spoke to the city
council about what happened and I want
you to listen to what he said
intolerance is an interesting word
tolerance intolerance hatred love
bigotry things like that because really
every culture has something that is
intolerant towards and something that
it's tolerance of
I mean there are things like murder and
rape and and you know stealing and just
crimes that we are intolerant towards as
a society and so every society has
something that's intolerant towards the
question is just what is our object of
intolerance and what is our object of
Tolerance
when I showed up Saturday all I did was
read from scripture on the sidewalk I
read from the Bible Galatians and said
by the way I wasn't reading Romans 1 I
wasn't reading any passage that spoke
against homosexuality or anything like
that I was reading a passage from the
Bible about love
and I was arrested no reason not given
any warning not told anything about my
amplification needed to be turning down
I was arrested and taken into custody
simply for reading the Bible on the
sidewalk one thing one thing to keep in
mind though when you watch that is um I
don't know if the police will try to
claim that uh well he was disturbing
you're using the megaphone you know uh
trans activists you you flip this around
and no one's getting arrested obviously
you know I've had trans activists many
times show up to my events and they
could have bull horns they could have
Sirens you know they show up with bull
horns uh uh um air horns Sirens that are
going off the whole time to drown you
out
cops will not step in they will not say
a damn word
one guy reading a Bible
gets arrested
on the other hand now anyone watching
that man uh knows that we just saw there
he knows that he's a far better person
to have around children than men
pretending to be women who talk to kids
about their sexual fantasies but Martha
Schrader was arrested anyway the drag
queens were able to continue
indoctrinating kids as the mothers of
those kids looked unapprovingly
it's the same thing that happens in
Canada preach the gospel go to jail
preach perversion please protect you
in many states in this country this will
soon become the norm a bill that
recently passed in the Michigan State
House called HB 4474. we're making a
hate crime to to cause someone to quote
feel terrorized frightened or threatened
and the bill specifies that sexual
orientation and gender identity or
expression are protected classes if you
make someone feel threatened because of
their gender identity you can go to
prison for five years
now what does it mean to make someone
feel threatened because of their gender
identity
well you know the answer to that
question trans activists have been
screaming for years at maximum volume
that unless you affirm them
unless you infirm everything they think
and feel
then you're committing literal violence
you're a terrorist you're engaging in
genocide
so yes this bill means that if you
refuse to lie about basic facts of
biology in the state of Michigan then
you'll go to jail just like that girl in
Britain
they'll haul you out of your home and uh
and they'll arrest you for telling the
truth
just as we're seeing in other other
parts of the world that also allegedly
are or were free
they'll take the fight right to you and
if you don't believe that consider what
happened on Wednesday to an elderly man
in Utah named Craig Robertson Robertson
was obese uh old 75 years old used a
cane to get around
he went to church on Sundays took care
of his blind son
but he also liked to post angry memes
and comments on social media mocking and
threatening Joe Biden Camille Harris
other random political figures
in response to those memes Before Dawn
on Wednesday the FBI went to Robertson's
home now neighbors report that as many
as 50 agents were on the scene
Craig Robertson soon after was shot dead
in a hail of bullets
now
why did FBI agents kill Robertson
exactly we don't know the FBI won't tell
us we asked them yesterday they refused
to explain the New York Post now reports
today that Robertson allegedly pointed a
gun at the agents and maybe he did we
don't know that at this point maybe
we'll find out more maybe we won't
but we do know that the neighbors are
all confused and Disturbed trying to
figure out why the federal government
would need to send dozens of armed
agents to a disabled elderly man's home
because of things he posted online
now if you saw them swarming his house
and didn't have any contacts you'd think
that they were taken down a drug kingpin
you never guess that the guy's crime was
a Facebook meme
so the question that many are asking
especially those at Robertson's
Community is whether this level of
response was actually necessary
did the FBI really consider Robertson a
credible threat to the president of the
United States
it's hard to believe
now it's not to defend the things that
Robertson posted online obviously
the point is that the most powerful law
enforcement organization in the country
which is funded by your tax dollars is
completely unwilling right now to
explain why they killed an American
citizen two days ago
they have no justification for why they
decided to go after him at 6 a.m in the
morning
they don't seem interested in providing
a justification
if you're living in the UK or Canada
then it's quite possible that none of
this is particularly shocking to you
you're used to this kind of thing
but if you thought the United States
could never descend into totalitarianism
as those countries have
then what's happening in many states
across this country should disabuse you
of that notion
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there